while genetics do create predispositions
and can increase your likelihood of
developing a certain disease your
lifestyle and the way that you're
navigating your life has a lot more sex
there are a bunch of studies looking at
identical twins exact same genes
different environments growing up nature
versus nurture what happens and these
Studies have been able to tease out what
is the impact of genetics versus
lifestyle and broadly speaking if we're
thinking about these big chronic
diseases like cardiovascular disease
type 2 diabetes fatty liver disease even
Alzheimer's dementia broadly speaking
your genes are controlling about 20
percent of your health fate and that
means that your environment and your
lifestyle is controlling 80 when you
come across that information then the
game changes from being disempowered to
being incredibly empowered